[Music]
hey guys how's the coat I haven't
blogged in a while Jenna peeler actually
just walk sorry now we're on our way to
a dance studio because I'm a dancer
guppy millions you got a fresh here all
right
okay I think you know they're dancing we
think yeah
[Music]
let's rap here rapping and dancing yeah
just have fun
maddie was so distressed there was so
much going on he's like get me out get
me out so right now we're gonna take
Maddie to the place that we originally
adopted him from and maybe just maybe a
brother or sister of his will be there
oh we could get him a brother or sister
like yes let's do it let's go we'll just
look Oh hold on hey Maddie let's go
visit your friends it's over here
Oh oh my god
babies oh no oh Jesus other door it is a
good or dumb though no I was just
showing you the adoption dog he does not
like his bow this is Axl Rose Oh
something about kid makes me laugh hi
babies we'll look at you you're sweet I
was looking online the other day I
wouldn't say actually and I thought you
guys you're not gonna believe it
I have little biggest hole in my pants
ever I got the car and went to dinner
and then I realized that the hole is
huge so I got a shovel too lemon on the
way to Kathy's party to dig up some pea
[Music]
this is all huge holes huge hole
I smell something it totally didn't even
start tonight I just feel something and
it didn't record it reward oh my gosh I
have to do every shoot of my blog but I
just can't reverse it out
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
my back I was like stop
yeah
everywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning it's the next day I had a
fun time at the party I had a fun time
at the shoot yesterday I've lost track
of this vlog
Jenna's inside getting us Starbucks
right now we are heading to a lala land
tour I'm sure you guys have probably
heard of the movie love the land if you
haven't it's actually a really really
good movie I was surprised how good it
actually was Oh
frigid oh gosh it's really cold it's so
frigid Oh what I'm stuck in the door my
hair oh gosh
Oh baby annoying today I have nothing
else to talk about
we're supposed to meet them at the top
of
top of the steps oh my gosh it's cold Oh
sir pile top in the bus we were supposed
to dress warm and guess what we didn't
do we're gonna dress more you look warm
though
thank you you too you don't feel what no
I don't know I feel very cool
we should have brought like hand warmers
like literally everywhere else in the
world is negative two degrees and we're
like I got it 60 classic la basics
and Joey is enjoying his tour more just
make my thumbnails owning the comma the
night will unfold
I never thought that I would be drowned
whoa look at you guys having a great
time look at those bag oh yes but Joe at
me sunglasses so he's borrowing jenna is
a really great spectacle so it was she's
like make sure you push the button if he
goes the bathroom baby
all right cons open a snap Jack only I
didn't do so we're the conservatory
about to fly my drone I'm not sure um
camera get your oh man I thought you
were leaving without us uh in my little
world you are both pros and cons talk to
you and Mick when you feel you don't
belong so tell me are you still here
it's beautiful
you just don't know how far in this
world I'll be right by your side
[Music]
right now we're heading down to see the
fetch it's a huge part of the movie it's
a big scene spoiler alert there's not
actually a bench in there
so this is where the bench was it should
be right here should be is it's not here
we tried so you finish our tour we're
taking Maddie to the dog park now he's
very excited clearly he's pretty pumped
up got a new hat to check the mail
Johnny Cupcakes has sent me this great
hotness of t-shirts back bar so when we
go to the dog park so I can't wait to go
to the dog park when we go to the dog
park it's gonna be gorgeous sweetheart
we're not gonna be at the dog park for
20 minutes this is 20 minutes until the
park dog park all this flavor when you
say dog Nemzek likey nothing at all he
now
[Music]
in this world
even
hello hello thank you thank you thank
you
hmm where do we go where should we go
where should we go oh we can go me
nicely go anywhere cuz I can fly for
miles so can i okay I got my backpack on
I've got two drones in my backpack I
have been poured in the mavet like drone
I got two drones one for my phone one
for all right you think we should do
like a phantom for pro Mavic comparison
cool this is my first time actually
flying the Phantom 4 outside of my house
so yeah there's that
Oh
oh that's nice Mike looks real nice real
quick I'd have time to charge up my
battery very much so I crowd I just had
to take it up take it back down there's
also a lot of magnetic interference I
can't imagine why because we're
basically surrounded by a bunch of metal
here you do the firmware update yeah I
just grabbed it and ran out of the house
without checking yeah I was like I'd get
in the car get a boot first get
Starbucks and then get in my car well I
guess I'm going to pop in another
battery in take a breath
[Music]
okay battery's totally dead on floor so
we're gonna drive back you need to put a
little label on yours with your little
name you may be one yeah cuz my loved
ones named to try to think of a creative
name is aiwei
[Music]
sure if he likes the TARDIS too much you
know go to the Apple store baby yes
it'll be so fun so today rumor has it
that there are air pods at the Apple
store so clearly I got to get there and
take a peek
mine are being shipped home to
Pennsylvania so if I do get a pair today
I'll be able to return those and I'll be
what I have some air buds for the flight
so that should be cool I'm gonna bring
my little Santa boy hello my little
Christmas King he is just love it is
damned
what's this what is where you're not
excited Hey look do you know what this
is
oh my god this guy's we got he last pair
of earplugs at the store they just have
received a shipment I got the last pair
I'm so excited I'm gonna go home when
I'm boxed these guys pretty sure he's
gotta go potty
[Music]
are you ready for this
Oh yep
chilly ready for Joey's party yeah so
Joey's having a white elephant gift
exchange party so for my gift I got a
Minecraft Lego set and the thing is
Starbucks like a $30 limit so Jenna got
single gumballs and then $10 to five
people are wrapped its gonna look like
alcohol oh cool maybe some ice
no no come back oh oh oh look at your
belly
awesome all do you want to play Oh
nice you are all users of your printer
[Music]
we're giving some tree they're actually
careful real slimy wait wait good boy
very good you're like my favorite time
of year right here a nice oh yeah oh I
don't remember
that's like I don't remember I remember
Frisco waiting for everybody house once
you go first
a lot more patient like looking good
that bad
Ivano here like making out of your dogs
oh my god yeah like yes I just did this
but it was last year I brought a little
bit of a gift but oh no I paid for it I
can't go to my channel Joey tell us the
rules and so number one come on pick a
gift a little different everyone and
that's a perfect one oh yeah is there is
there a limit on how many times some
people can be stolen
what no they can be so my bad yes
what happened Jenna so Jenna got the
Kylie Jenner calendar which is great if
you're a you know come on or
everywhere college ever everywhere I'm
gonna go for Trish's
[Music]
oh my god I'm taking it home take those
off your body this is my crack
[Applause]
that's interesting yeah yeah
[Music]
is it obvious or was breaking are you to
give you my present bag I can get all
hyped up on caffeine and do Lego set you
guys know good job Jen check Tommy John
smithing army than they would have
looked on you know a Friday actually
look really good
I ended up with some really cool toys so
so
hi sweetie Oh you miss you so much Oh Oh
give it a sniff I got this for you
let it go smell look at him get all play
with it
Maddie it was either this or Kylie
Jenner calendar I would have let you
peed on that one hi sir we're about to
get on the plane
I have packed so much stuff and when I
say so much stuff it might not look like
there's a lot of stuff but inside of
these bags there's a lot of equipment
computer TV and go through this stuff it
would take me way too long so we're just
gonna pack all the stuff up and hope for
the best
I'll show you later just trust me it's a
lot I kind of feel like I'm cheating on
Apple recently because not only have I
been carrying around a pixel Bowman I've
also been gaming on my PC quite a bit
this is probably my favorite bag I got
two drones alone in the big compartment
one in the small compartment I'm so
excited to go back to my parents house
because there I can actually fly drones
freely there's so much open space a lot
of places to go everywhere I feel like I
go in LA you just can't really fly them
so yeah it's sad right now I'm gonna
head to Jenna's house so we can go to
the dog park
so I'm eating Jenna and Matt we're going
to go to the dog park do it at the dog
park had to drop off all of my stuff I
just keep leave your stuff I packed it's
going to be ridiculous
getting us all home and then back to law
school is we don't get in till really
late tonight it's gonna be a long
freaking day but take Maddie the dog
park hold it nice and tired
I'm waiting for my Starbucks and look
who it is hi Matt my basset human the
Starbucks has been ordered for your
order
I got peppermint mocha frappuccino two
one finchy hibiscus refresher spinach
feta wrap sausage egg and cheese and a
water Kate there's little Matty having a
good time at the dog park lots and lots
of other white little pups we gotta go
to the airport now
[Music]
we get a lot of stuff but there's
actually not that I didn't
get going should I just leave my
sunglasses on worse yeah inconspicuous
TMZ is gonna think you're someone
important
just a few items just a quick trip home
Jen around
oh my god we look like you're gonna be
backpacking across Europe forever when
we went to Europe for two months and we
had way less than what we have now oh
good times
this is a super cool pet relief area
this used to be like a smoking section
but now they have no smoking signs up no
smoking no smoking
oh you got an ear this is great because
we can just basically hang
until our play and
I've got to get my peel do you want you
go ahead you know yeah I'll jump in here
medicham here's the bottle this is so
cool
I'm so happy I have over my earbud set
up an outlet in 2008 like downloading
downloading downloading
late every time I smile this one
[Music]
guys what a long trip holy moly
we're finally home John also the trip I
spent digging around for my air pods
I managed to find a few options on
Amazon that I think will help keep them
in I also found something that was
actually quite cool you can actually
sync them to an Android or other device
that has Bluetooth you just have to set
it up so I was kind of like switching
back and forth between my iPhone and my
pixel phone and of course wasn't audible
because that's the way that I survived
most long flights I started listening to
console wars as a sweet little holiday
treat check out audible.com slash
iJustine you guys can get a 30-day free
trial and also a free book so go check
that out and let me know what book you
guys decide to get listen do it on your
holiday travel you don't have to go
anywhere for holiday travel oh hi
sweetie oh my goodness hi I was just
telling them if they don't have to go
anywhere for holiday travel that's good
have you been a good sleep boy you just
won't find evil cold
[Music]
be sure to check out all the black op
slash agency and I will see you guys
very very soon
happy holidays and place our bots on the
line and you will see it'll turn red
green red green and he's like yay
so with this piece of paper we're going
to be able to code our O's about to tell
you what we wanted to do so much like
the puzzle can just be like yo go this
way